en el vídeo anterior estábamos viendo
esta función que tengo aquí esta función
que es sumamente no lineal y la
estábamos representando como una
transformación que lleva a cada punto x
m al punto x base no de james quien seno
de x además nos estuvimos acercando a un
punto específico y permíteme escribirles
a qué punto nos acercamos nos acercamos
al punto menos 2,1 menos 2,1 y lo que
hice fue agregar algunas rectas
adicionales a la cuadrícula alrededor
del punto que podemos ver aquí así
podemos ver el detalle de lo que la
transformación le hace a los puntos que
están en torno a ese punto menos 21 y de
este lado en el cuadro tenemos la
versión ampliada de ese entorno y lo que
vimos fue que aunque la función como un
todo se comporta como una transformación
que luce bastante complicada alrededor
de ese solo punto se ve como una función
lineal tiene linealidad local así que lo
que quiero mostrarles aquí
es una matriz que va a indicar la
función lineal que se ve como el cuadro
de la versión ampliada y esto va a ser
una matriz de 2 x 2 así que la voy a
escribir justo aquí y me voy a tomar una
matriz de 2 x 2 que me den esa
linealidad local y la manera de pensarla
es primero volver a nuestra
configuración original antes de la
transformación esta que tengo aquí y
pensar en un pequeño cambio el x primero
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa cuando
tomamos un pequeño cambios a la derecha
es decir voy a pensar una pequeña d
es un pequeño cambio en la dirección x y
en lo que esto se convierte después de
la transformación porque va a ser un
pequeño cambio también en el espacio de
salida así que permíteme dibujar dentro
del cuadrado en lo que ese pequeño
cambio se convierte ojo observa que este
ya no está completamente en la dirección
x tiene un componente hacia la derecha
pero también tiene un componente hacia
abajo y para poder representar esto de
una manera agradable lo que voy a hacer
es en el lugar de escribir esta función
que tengo aquí que toman un vector y nos
da un vector de salida lo voy a escribir
mejor de la siguiente manera voy a
representarlo como un vector que nos dé
dos funciones separadas ahora voy a
tener a dos funciones escalares y la
primera la voy a llamar así
efe 1d x james
y bueno en la otra componente también
voy a tener otra función f 2 que también
depende de xm y ahora observan estas dos
son funciones escalares entonces tal vez
sea mejor para que así entiendas esta
explicación que voy a dar solamente les
estoy dando un nombre a efe uno de que
james es la función x + seno de james y
f2 de que james es la función que más el
seno de x ahora cuando veo el vector del
cuadrado este vector resultante de tener
una pequeña de x es decir un pequeño
cambio en el espacio de entrada este
ahora corresponde a un movimiento
bidimensional en el espacio de salida y
el componente en x de ese movimiento es
algo que consideramos como un pequeño
cambio pero ahora en f1 es decir ahora
tenemos un pequeño cambio en f1 y si
hacemos justo esta división la magnitud
del cambio en f1 entre la magnitud del
cambio en x vamos a obtener cuánto
cambia el espacio de salida con respecto
al
de entrada básicamente aumenta la escala
hasta que sea un vector de magnitud
normal no un pequeño empujón porque es
algo más constante que no se reduce
mientras nos acercamos más y más y más y
luego del mismo modo el cambio y la
dirección james el componente vertical
de este cambio que o como todavía está
provocado por de x va a ser un pequeño
cambio en f2 es decir nos estamos
fijando ahora en la componente jet del
espacio de salida ya que recuerda que
estamos viendo el espacio de salida que
fue provocado por el cambio parcial en
la dirección x así que déjame ponerlo
entre el cambio parcial en la dirección
x y de nuevo me gusta pensar esto como
que estamos dividiendo por una pequeña
cantidad este pequeño cambio en f2 es en
realidad un empujón muy pero muy pequeño
dividido entre la magnitud de un empujón
pequeño inicial que lo provocó estamos
obteniendo algo que es básicamente un
número algo que no se reduce cuando
consideramos más en más versiones
ampliadas entonces eso
lo que sucede cuando damos un pequeño
cambio en la dirección x ahora bien otra
cosa que podemos considerar es un
pequeño cambio en la dirección james ya
que queremos saber si tomamos un pequeño
cambio que sea vertical una pequeña
cantidad de hacia arriba entonces qué le
sucederá cuando le aplicamos la
transformación y como se ve es este
vector que déjame ponerlo todavía tiene
una componente hacia arriba pero también
tienen una componente hacia la derecha y
ahora voy a escribir sus componentes
como la segunda columna de esta matriz
porque como sabemos cuando estamos
representando la transformación lineal
con una matriz la primera columna les
dice hacia dónde va el primer vector
base y la segunda columna muestran hacia
dónde va el segundo vector base y si
esto te parece desconocido revisa el
vídeo anterior o tal vez vayan y vean el
contenido de álgebra lineal pero para
averiguar las coordenadas de ese vector
hacemos básicamente lo mismo vamos a
decir que en primer lugar tenemos un
cierto cambio
dirección x el componente x es ese
vector que va a estar dado como un
cambio parcial también en f1 es decir en
la primera componente de salida porque
recuerda aquí estamos viendo el espacio
de salida donde estamos trabajando con f
1 y con ep 2 y estamos planteando cuál
fue el cambio que fue causado por un
pequeño cambio ahora en la dirección y
entonces el cambio en f1 provocado por
un pequeño cambio la dirección tiempo
esto nos da nuestra primera componente
de salida y luego la componente jet de
nuestra salida el componente del cambio
en el espacio de salida bien va a ser
ahora un cambio en f2 ok provocado por
un pequeño dèiem provocado por un
pequeño cambio en y por supuesto todo
esto es muy específico al punto donde
empezamos al punto menos 2.1 así que en
cada una de estas derivadas parciales
habrá que evaluarlas en
este punto de menos 2 a 1 y con eso
obtendremos cada uno de los componentes
de la matriz en el punto menos 2,1 en
cada componente van a obtener algún
número y eso les dará una matriz de 2
por 2 muy concreta que va a representar
la transformación lineal que este 4
representan una vez ampliado entonces
esta matriz de aquí tiene un nombre
bastante importante la matriz de todas
las derivadas parciales se le conoce con
el nombre de matriz hakobyan a déjeme
notarlo y bueno la podemos entender como
una matriz que tienen toda la
información de las derivadas parciales
está tomando en cuenta las dos
componentes de salida f 1 de x 72 de
quiché como también los dos componentes
de entrada x james que en este caso los
vamos a evaluar como menos 2 1 pero como
espero que vean es mucho más que
solamente una manera de registrar lo que
pasó con todas las derivadas parciales
existe una razón para organizarla de
esta manera y realmente cae con esta
idea de linealidad local
para que entiendan lo que la matriz
hakobyan am fundamentalmente representa
es decir cómo se ve una transformación
cuando la amplían acerca de un punto
específico entonces todo esto toma
sentido y en el siguiente vídeo voy a
continuar y realmente lo que voy a hacer
es calcular esta matriz solo para
mostrarles cómo se ve el proceso y cómo
llegamos al resultado que corresponde a
la imagen que estamos observando así que
hasta entonces